محمد كيف تبدو الاوضاع الانسانيه في غزه
بعد قصف خزان المياه الرئيسي في تل الزعتر
الاوضاع الانسانيه صعبه جدا بموازاه القصف
والمجازر التي تجري في اكثر من منطقه من
قطاع غزه هنالك حاله موازيه ما يطلق عليها
حرب التجويع ومركز المركز الاورو متوسطي
كان يتحدث عن حرب تجويه فعليه تجري في
مدينه غزه تحديدا وشمال قطاع غزه بفعل كما
هو معلوم انقطاع المياه منذ اليوم الاول
لاعلان الحرب وطبعا الكهرباء و قله او
انعدام وجود الوقود نحن نتحدث عن عدم
امكانيه الوصول الى الخبز رحله البحث عن
الخبز هو الشغل الشاغل بالنسبه لمن هم
احياء ومن بقيوا في مدينه غزه والشمال
وهذا يؤثر بشكل كبير لدينا رضع لدينا كبار
سن لدينا اصحاب امراض مزمنه هم لا يجدون
الماء ولا يجدون الطعام الاسواق بالتاكيد
خاليه ولا تستطيع ان
تصمد يعني نتحدث عن تخزين مثلا مثلا لا
تستطيع ان تصمد على مدار شهر غزه لا تنتج
هي بالاصل محاصره وتدخل اليها البضائع من
الخارج الان وقد نفذت قد نفذت هذه البضائع
من من الاسواق
وانقطعت الكهرباء والوقود حتى المخابز
نتحدث عن 11د مخبزا تم قصفه بالاضافه الى
ما جاء في البدايه من خزان خزان المياه
الرئيسي الذي تم قصفه وبالتالي حتى المياه
المالحه التي تستخدم ل عتين في البيوت
الان انقطعت خيارات الناس اشبه ما تكون
معدومه في الحصول على الخبز الدقيق من
المخابز التي ان وجدت فان الوقوف امامها
لطوابير وربما يستغرق الوقت لايام